ta monsieur eric straumann merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
et j'associe mon collègue michel sordi
député du haut rhin depuis le dernier
remaniement de ce premier ministre vous
êtes à la tête d'un gouvernement qui a
selon l'expression de notre collègue
jean glavany un parfum de quatrième
république
les fonctions d 39 membres du
gouvernement ne sont pas bien connus du
grand public
et on constate que certains ministres ne
maîtrise pas mieux le contour de leur
propre portefeuille les couacs dans ce
contexte sont inévitables et sous la
vème république il appartient au chef du
gouvernement de mettre fin à ces
dissonances madame ségolène royal
ministre de l'écologie a annoncé la
fermeture de fessenheim pour 2018
madame emmanuelle cosse ministre du
logement vient de déclarer ce week end
que la centrale va cesser de fonctionner
dès cette année 2016
cette cacophonie pourrait prêter à
sourire monsieur le premier ministre
mais il s'agit de l'avenir de 2000
salariés qui vivent aujourd'hui dans l'
angoisse du lendemain
alors monsieur le ministre quelle est la
position officielle du gouvernement sur
ce sujet
la parole est à monsieur emmanuel macron
ministre de l'économie de l'industrie et
du numérique alors à les cacher leur
joie
le député comme vous le savez la loi de
transition énergétique a donné la règle
qui consiste à articuler justement les
capacités nucléaires française
puisqu'elle a plafonné à 63,2 gigawatts
ses capacités ce qui suppose ce qui
suppose yeux verts et bien un poids bien
culte et que des capacités soit ouverte
pour que d'autres puissent être fermé et
réciproquement
en vertu de cette loi en octobre 2015
madame ségolène royal a reçu la demande
faite par l'entreprise edf d'un décalage
dans le temps de l'ouverture des
capacités via flamanville et dans le
même temps elle a pris note que
l'hypothèse sur laquelle travaillent et
edf pour faire face à cette ouverture de
nouvelles capacités flamanville
c'était la fermeture c'est bien des deux
réacteurs de fessenheim
c'est cela qu'on sait depuis octobre
dans ce contexte là qu'est ce qui va se
passer en 2016 et bien edf edf doit
faire la demande
et c'est dans la main d'edf aujourd'hui
car il vous plait goûter la raconte à
une demande donc de la part de
l'entreprise et sur la base de cette
demande
un décret d'abrogation d'autorisation
d'exploiter la centrale de fessenheim
sera pris cette année et donc c'est ce
décret qui sera pris en 2016 suite à la
demande qui sera fait durant l'année par
edf suite à cette demande c'est qu'a
rappelé la ministre
hier il ne peut pas y avoir d'engagement
le mois le mois pour une fermeture
effective parce que cela demande une
série de décisions techniques une série
de mises aux normes
une série justement de mesures sous le
contrôle de l'asn pour que la centrale
de fessenheim et les deux réacteurs
concernés soit fermé et donc aucune
garantie ne peut être donnée en terme de
temps ce serait irresponsable de le
faire par contre tout sera fait pour que
suite à cette décision qui sera prise en
2016 ce soit fait en bon ordre dans un
calendrier bien ordonné
le contrôle de l'asn dans le résumé des
salles jeanine dubié